today on the matt walsh show a woman
encounters a naked man in the women's
locker room and then does what so many
others these days refuse to do she
objects loudly and publicly she had the
courage to be sane and normal which is
something that many
in our culture lack today we'll talk
about that also five headlines tucker
carlson reveals that the nsa is spying
on him
a majority of the conservative
quote-unquote justices on the supreme
court
refused to take up a case dealing with
the trans bathroom issue
and a daily beast reporter reveals his
utter horror at the sight of families
eating meals together at restaurants
and our daily cancellation we'll discuss
the brave white british man who has
come out as a non-binary korean though
many on the left have refused to accept
his trans-racial identity which i just
think is unthinkable
we'll talk about all of that and more
today on the matt wall show
[Music]
now we check in with policy genius uh
look we've all got a lot going on this
summer i know i do
but thankfully there's one thing you can
cross off your list and that is getting
life insurance with policy genius and it
really is a responsibility
that uh that that you have you have
people that depend on you as
as i certainly do then this is something
that you can't afford to put off
you might put it off before until it's
too late if someone relies on your
financial support whether it's a child
an aging parent or even a business
partner
partner you need life insurance policy
genius makes it easy to compare quotes
from over a dozen top insurers all in
one place
why compare well you could save 50 or
more on life insurance by comparing
quotes
with policy genius you could save 1300
or more per year on life insurance
by using policy genius to compare
policies and who can afford to leave
those kinds of savings
aside the license experts at policy
genius work for you not the insurance
company so you can trust them to help
you navigate every step of the shopping
and buying experience
and they just make it really easy for
you to take care of this
thing that you need to do cross it off
the list and you can do that right now
all you got to do is head to
policygenius.com in minutes
you can solve this problem and get it
all worked out head to
possiblegenius.com to get started right
now
policy genius when it comes to insurance
it's nice to get it right
we have reached a point where it
requires courage to simply be normal
i don't mean normal in the privacy of
your own home or when you're whispering
with your friends and hushed tones
hoping that nobody hears or finds out
that you possess common sense
because you don't want anyone to know
someone might hear us they'll know we
have common sense
i mean publicly normal it requires
courage to be a normal person
going through daily life and saying
things that normal people say
and reacting to things like a normal
person would react
now this shouldn't require any courage
at all normal people should act normal
and say normal things by default because
they're normal
but it's become an act of courage
because so many normal insane people
have gone silent
and are keeping their normalcy and their
sanity to themselves
and it's because of this state of
affairs that we need to make a special
point of applauding the woman featured
in a viral video which
you may have seen by now loudly
objecting to the sight of a naked man in
the ladies rock
locker room at a spa in los angeles the
incident unfolded
i guess a few days ago at the wii spa in
la
the woman films herself confronting the
staff at the establishment after she
sees a man
in the women's locker room naked
and parading his nude body around women
and girls and
she she knows that he's a man because he
has well a penis
and that's the first giveaway so here's
how she presents her arguments
i find it to be quite eloquent and
powerful in its simplicity
let's listen now i just want to be clear
with you
it's okay it's okay for a man to go into
the women's section
show his penis around the other woman
young little girls
under age your spa we spa
condone that is that what you're saying
like i
asked it's so he could stay there
he could stay there what sexual
orientation i see
it lets me know he's a man he's a man
he is a man he is not no female
he is not a female he is not a female
hold on
so to restate and summarize her argument
she says
um i see a penis
that lets me know he's a man he's not a
female
then she repeats over and over again
he's a female he's a female that really
is indeed
the long and short of it no pun intended
he has a penis
he's a man he's not a woman that's it
and he shouldn't be in a place reserved
for women
they apparently even have they have
obviously locker rooms
and they're labeled women men
he's not a woman so he doesn't belong
there he might say he's a woman he might
say he feels like a woman
he might wish he was a woman he might
wish upon a falling star that he's a
woman he might dream about being a woman
he might want people to see him as a
woman but wishes and wants and dreams
and feels and likes
do not change the physical reality of
the situation which is that he's a man
plain and simple you don't need to be a
conservative to see that
i don't know what this woman's political
orientation is uh
maybe she's conservative maybe it
doesn't matter
you don't need to be right wing to know
that a dude walking around with his
penis hanging out is a dude
any more than a scuba diver needs to be
a right-wing activist in order to see
that the large
fish with a dorsal fin and razor-sharp
teeth is a shark
and not an octopus or an oyster this is
a matter of the most
basic reality there's nothing inherently
political or ideological about it
at least there shouldn't be this woman
is merely
observing reality living in reality and
reacting to an outrageous and
inappropriate
situation the way that one who lives in
reality should
now you notice that the staff member
has no argument to counter hers they
have no rejoinder to the
he has a penis so he's a man contention
there is no rejoice there's no
counterpoint
reality is reality a little bit later in
the video
a white knight rides in to try and
defend the naked man showing his penis
to little girls
and um here's how that went
there's no such thing as transgender he
hasn't
okay he has a penis he has penises
hanging out
okay no i'm not one actually i'm a woman
who knows how to stand up and speak up
for my right
as a woman i have a right to feel
comfortable
without a man exposing himself
okay no you go somewhere else okay so
that's right
no he's not a transgender he has a penis
just like you do
are you are you are you are you i
understand no yeah
okay it's not okay that's not okay okay
that's traumatizing to see that
i'm a woman i think this is a place
right here i'm told only for women
so how dare you sit up here and tell me
i don't have a right as a woman
i'm telling you he has a penis a full
and testicle
okay sure just pure insanity
we're we're standing around
having a debate about whether the guy
with a penis
is a woman but we see that guy there he
says oh you see he's a transgender
person
he says with a smarmy grin as he
condescends to a woman
who simply wants to get changed without
a creepy naked man hovering nearby
as if that's some kind of outrageous and
cumbersome request
he's transgender you see oh no no he's
transgender
yeah and who cares
who cares that he's a transgender person
what does that mean transgender
transgender refers to his psychological
state it refers to how he
allegedly views himself which is
irrelevant to everyone
except him locker rooms are not meant to
house people based on psychological
states it's a locker room not a mental
asylum
if a little girl is forced to watch a
man a grown man undress himself
it's not going to be any less
traumatizing just because the grown man
feels a certain way inside
oh no you see little girl i this is how
i feel
it's not about how you feel that's not
the point
now this is obvious and only needs to be
explained to people who have made the
decision
to delude themselves which is why it's
useless explaining it really
instead normal and sane people need to
stand up
be loud and treat this insanity with the
contempt and derision it deserves
as this lady did the problem is that
normalcy and sanity are so
taboo these days that even those who
protest the insanity
will often try to reinforce the insanity
as they protest it
so a perfect example can be found in a
different incident in this same spa a
few years ago and i haven't seen this
mentioned by
any this is the story's gotten some
coverage in other publications i haven't
seen anyone mention this
there's a yelp review um
which is from 2018 so it's not like this
was just written yesterday
uh a yelp review for the wii spawn los
angeles
uh 2018 and it sounds pretty familiar
this is what it says
reading now it says quote i would give
this place
five stars a week ago but last night
i had the most disturbing experience in
the women's locker room
upon checking in the clerk advised us
that there was a transgender male
in the women's locker room okay no
problem i'm not the type to discriminate
against people but once in the women's
area i saw the mentioned
transgender individual uh in all his
glory
and still had a male organ hanging there
okay
no fuss that surgery is very expensive
anyway so i go my go about my routine
and i get to the shower room
he was almost next to me showering too
when i start to overhear
uh the conversation that he's having
with a lady that was also in the shower
area
i clearly heard him say that he has had
sex with probably 100 women
and that he was looking for a female
girlfriend to share his time with
he also mentioned that he uses cocaine
and lsd to relax
okay not my business what he uses to
relax but hey
a transgender person does not act like a
guy around women
nor do they state how much they like
women or how much they like having sex
with them
this guy is not transgender he seems to
be just a
pervy in quotes pervy and given his
accent he's from another country
europe i believe um i like how she
equates those two things by the way
being a pervy and being from uh the
country of europe but we'll leave that
aside
yeah he's a pervy one of those people
from europe not that i'm disagreeing
with
her her uh her assumptions anyway
i heard from other ladies there um there
that he goes there quite often
i have nothing against gay people or
transgender etc but every gay guy i know
uses the men's locker room when in the
spa
management said that according to the
law there was nothing they could do
yes they can reserve their right to
provide services to anyone
that's uh not against the law they can't
deny entrance to this person based on
his behavior
or they can deny entrance to this person
based on his behavior not on his gender
i enjoy going to the wii spawn it's uh
it's not fair to me or other women to be
put in this position when you basically
have to leave the spa
because you feel uncomfortable in such a
situation i wouldn't have minded the
situation at all
if the guy was really transgender but
obviously he's not
you wouldn't have minded him swinging
his penis all around
as long as he really felt like a woman
while he did it
so you've got a strange man with a penis
showering next to you
in the women's locker room and you
wouldn't have minded that
as long as he really felt like a woman
what that doesn't make any sense at all
have you ever once objected to a
biological woman in the women's locker
room on the basis that
she might have felt like a man i mean
have you ever been in a women's
locker room and uh listened to the
conversations that a woman was having
and uh an actual woman and then and then
come to the judgment that well she's not
really a woman inside and she doesn't
belong here and therefore i don't feel
i don't feel comfortable getting changed
around her
no obviously not
you have a problem with sharing a locker
room
with a naked man because he's a man
and you should have a problem with that
there could be no other reason to object
there doesn't need to be any other
reason those are all the reasons you
need
and yet this person like so many others
feels that they can't just come out
as the woman in the video did and
straightforwardly say
this is a man i don't care how he feels
that's irrelevant
he shouldn't be getting naked around a
bunch of women and young girls
period
in our day and age sanity pays tribute
to insanity
so often even as sanity meekly asserts
itself it feels that it still must
validate the very insanity that
it's objecting to which is to say that
sanity surrenders
because when you when you object to a
man in the women's locker room on the
basis that
uh he doesn't really feel like a woman
the problem with having men and allowing
transgender
men in women's locker room is that what
if someone's pretending to be
transgender that's the problem
you hear this from conservatives all the
time again you don't have to be
conservative to object but
that is that is a way that conservatives
will often couch their arguments
i i don't have any problem with genuine
transgenders but what if someone's
pretending
you know people always ask me what we
can do
to save ourselves from civilizational
collapse reverse the tide reclaim the
culture etc etc well
if there's any hope of anything like
that happening
it has to start with doing what this
woman did
which in any other time or place would
have been totally unremarkable
we have to be sane and normal in public
now if you want a solution that will
absolve you of the duty to be publicly
sane
and yet will allow you to enjoy a
cultural victory that you've done
nothing to help achieve
then you'll be disappointed because no
such solution exists
one of the major problems in our society
today is that sanity
has retreated
there's no solution that will allow it
to remain
in hiding it has to come out into the
open
and be loud and make demands and state
very basic truths like the truth that
the person showing his penis in a locker
room
is not a woman that truth is one of many
that shouldn't need to be said but it
does
and we're the ones who have to say it
now let's get to our five headlines
well this is a good time to tell you
about relief band after uh my
20-hour car ride and fortunately as the
person
driving uh i i don't have to deal with
car sickness as much
but other people in the car like my
daughter do that's why we always bring
on any car ride
especially 20 hours we always bring
relief band uh if you get carsick or if
you deal with nausea in any other
context you need to try relief band
relief band is the number one fda
cleared anti-nausea wristband that's
been clinically proven to quickly
relieve and effectively prevent nausea
and vomiting associated with motion
sickness anxiety
migraine hangover morning sickness
chemotherapy and so much more
the product is 100 drug-free it's
non-drowsy
uh which is great as well especially if
you're
you know you're like i'm taking an uber
or something in the middle of the day
you don't want to be drowsy for the rest
of the day just put on relief ban and it
provides all natural relief with
zero side effects for as long as needed
the technology was originally created
over 20 years ago in hospitals but now
it's available to the to the public
and you've got to take advantage of that
you can ensure that nausea is never the
reason to miss out on life's important
moments
right now relief band has an exclusive
offer just for matt walsh listeners
if you go to reliefband.com and use
promo code wall she'll receive 20
off plus free shipping and a no
questions asked 30-day money-back
guarantee so head to r-e-l-i-e-f-b-a-n-d
dot com and use our code walsh for 20
off all right let's
begin here on his show last night tucker
carlson
made a shocking statement i call it
shocking
shocking at least if you're utterly
oblivious and naive
but either way this is this is what he
said the war on terror
now ongoing for 20 years has pivoted in
its aims
the war on terror is now being waged
against american citizens opponents of
the regime
we saw this on display on january 6. we
told you a couple of weeks ago based on
language and publicly available
indictments
that the fbi clearly had foreknowledge
of the riot at the capitol that day
and the agents we spoke to this weekend
confirmed that is true
quote the fbi had sources in that crowd
confidential sources snitches that's 100
percent
certain but it's not just political
protesters the government is spying on
yesterday we heard from a whistleblower
within the us government
who reached out to warn us that the nsa
the national security agency
is monitoring our electronic
communications and is planning to leak
them in an attempt to take this show off
the air
now that's a shocking claim and
ordinarily we'd be skeptical of it is
illegal for the nsa to spy on american
citizens it's a crime
it's not a third world country things
like that should not happen in america
but unfortunately they do happen and in
this case they did happen
the whistleblower who is in a position
to know
repeated back to us information about a
story that we are working on
that could have only come directly from
my texts
and emails there's no other possible
source for that information
period the nsa captured that information
without our knowledge and did it for
political reasons
the biden administration is spying on us
we have confirmed that
now the uh so i i think
what you hear there are going to be two
strategies um from the left and
responding to these claims
there already has been and it's really
one and then the other
um the first is to just deny it
and and say there's no way this is true
our intelligence agencies would never do
such a thing
these are benevolent our intelligence
agencies are benevolent and kind
even though we know that the nsa spies
on american citizens that's been
confirmed we already know
they would never do that this is absurd
even some so-called conservatives
jonah goldberg among among them came out
immediately after this segment heard and
say
no way didn't happen can't be true not
the nsa i know
come on i've known this nsa
these are this this is these are good
people they would never do such a thing
uh so that's the first strategy is just
to is just is to accuse tucker carlson
of what making this up this whole story
making it up out of thin air
but then when um
more evidence is presented that even
they can't deny
they're going to immediately switch
course and say
okay they're spying on him but uh but
i'm glad they are because he's
a terrorist you're kind of seeing
a little bit of both right now doing the
whole thing that this
isn't true but even if it was uh it
would be fine
but you'll see the
stark changing course eventually when it
becomes undeniable this is actually
happening did happen
that's when they'll say yeah i'm glad it
did
and the left is moving to that more and
more
of um
embracing these a display of power like
this
this is one of the reasons why as we
always talk about you know
pointing out the the hypocrisy of the
left
doesn't really accomplish much because
the hypocrisy is the point
it's all about it's all about cult it's
all about power
and they have the power in the culture
so they're allowed to have one standard
for themselves and another standard for
you and when you point out the hypocrisy
their answer in so many words is yeah
thanks for noticing you're right that's
exactly right
we're in control you aren't
do we said because we said so do as we
say not as we do
you know it's a power move
and eventually you'll see the same thing
with this kind of thing
yeah you're damn right
you get up there saying things we don't
like night after night you have the gall
to do that
you're the most successful cable news
show
on tv by a mile
that's we can't allow that to happen
we're going to use all the tools at our
disposal to take you down
all right now this is from the the ap
says the u.s supreme court on monday
rejected a virginia school board's
appeal to reinstate its transgender
bathroom ban
handing a victory to transgender rights
groups and a former high school student
who fought in court
for six years to overturn the ban after
learning that the high school
the high court rather refused to hear
the board's appeal
gavin grimm now 22 said that
quote unquote his long battle is over
we won honored to have been part of this
victory
uh grimm was a 15 year old student at a
at
glouchester high school when he was
banned from using the boys bathroom
again air quotes around he i'm reading
the language in the ap
article the gloucester county school
board's policy required grimm to use
restrooms that corresponded with his
biological sex which is female
or private bathrooms grimm filed a
federal lawsuit that wound its way
through the court for six years grimm
said
that being forced to use the nurse's
room a private bathroom and the girl's
restroom was humiliating
and severely interfered with his
education
so uh there
many consensus concessions were made by
the school
more concessions than i would make if i
was running the school board
if i'm in charge girls bathroom boys
bathroom you're a girl that's where you
go
you don't like it it makes you feel
uncomfortable um
that's your that's your issue you got to
sort that out
that's not an issue for us to solve
but they went beyond that and they said
we will find you private bathrooms you
have your own bathroom all to yourself
you know what what what what high
schooler wouldn't love to have that
get your own bathroom i mean the
bathrooms everyone uses those are all
grimy and gross and there's you know
people writing all over the bathroom
stalls and
it's just it's it's not a pleasant
situation
we'll give you your own private one
multiple private whatever you happen to
be in the building we'll make sure
there's not one far away for that you
can use all
it's all it's all yours that's not good
enough
no um and uh
anyway continuing it says grimm said
that being forced to use the nurse's
room a private bathroom in the girls
restroom was humiliating and severely
interfered with
his education her education the supreme
court left in place
lower court rulings that found the
policy unconstitutional
justices samuel alito and clarence
thomas voted to hear the board's appeal
so only thomas and alito
wanted to even hear this case the rest
of the supreme court justices didn't
want to go anywhere near it including
the other
so-called conservatives on the court
including all three of the so-called
conservatives that trump appointed
this this by the way is supposed to be
when i ask
you know what what are donald trump
four years in office two of which he had
uh he had
republican control of the whole
government um
what are his lasting achievements
because there were a lot of sort of
minor achievements that were
that the biden administration overturned
in like 30 seconds
so what are his lasting achievements
and the answers i usually get are tax
cuts
fantastic that's what republicans always
give you and then supreme court justices
well if if he whiffed on all three three
supreme court justices then what are we
left
only tax cuts
because there's no reason i mean uh
the the idea
that you have a constitutional right a
constitutional right to access
whatever bathroom you want dependent on
your psychological state
this is an outrageous idea
that any true conservative or
originalist or whatever label you want
to put on it
in in a position on the supreme court
should want to hear this case
but they won't go anywhere near it
so as it stands right now this uh this
remains intact it is it is
it is unconstitutional
that that man with his penis hanging out
in the it would be
unconstitutional to tell him to go to
the men's uh
locker room where is this constitutional
right
where in the constitution exactly do you
find the god-given
right to access whatever bathroom you
want according to your psychological
state
i would love to get in an answer to that
question but uh we're not going to get
an answer
right now anyway because the supreme
court and these conservative justices
won't even won't even touch it won't go
anywhere near it fantastic all right
staying the realm of
lgbt stuff the nfl put out a commercial
in honor of pride month
um which they're coming in here at the
11th hour i'm starting to get looking a
little concerned
because we're getting to the end of
primal we've only got a few days left
and the nfl hadn't put out a pride
commercial yet
yeah they changed their their logo on
twitter and they put the rainbow flag
and all that
uh but that's that's not enough we need
the we need the virtue signaling
commercial
and finally at the very last minute they
come in and they've got the commercial
and uh let's watch it i'll have to
narrate a little bit because
it's just words on the screen but let's
let's watch this commercial
so it says football is gay
football is gay football is lesbian
football is beautiful
football is queer football is life
football is by it's going too fast
football is bisexual football is
american the football is accepting
football is everything
football is for everyone
football is bisexual
what in the world does that mean exactly
football is everything no football isn't
everything football is really a
particular thing it's a it's a game with
certain rules and that's all that
football is it's not anything bigger
than that
but we know everything is everything now
everything has to
nothing can just be what it is
you can't have a thing and it's that
thing and that's it and it's nothing
else
everything has to be everything
everything is whatever i feel like it
should be for me
which is to say that everything is
nothing and nothing is anything
are you confused yet i am that's of
course part of the point
i want to read this to moving on daily
beast
daily beast columnist wadjihat ali
always with a lot of great insight
coming from this guy
and he tweeted this a couple days ago
got a lot of attention
he said i feel america has forgotten
that we're still in the middle of a
pandemic that has killed more than six
hundred thousand people
and there's a deadly delta plus strain
and our kids are still not vaccinated
psy i see packed restaurants and people
inside stores and malls
and their kids aren't wearing masks i
feel i'm in a horror movie
first of all what kind of boring horror
movies are you watching
oh yeah we know that you know those
horror movies where
people are spending time with their kids
and their families and their friends
and they're eating at restaurants and
they're having barbecues
and they're going to the pool and they
have a good time
and then they go home and everything is
fine and they go to bed
the end you know those horror movies
you know the horror movies where like
nothing bad happens and everything's
okay
because that's at these these packed
restaurants
i've been to a lot of these packed
restaurants we've got a ton of them here
in nashville
and i think it's great you know
i i never would have before all of this
i i don't think i ever walked into a
packed busy place
and thought this is awesome i'm so glad
that all these people are here
that's one positive thing that's come of
this
it's maybe it's it's actually made me
slightly less
inherently anti-social and that'll
probably wear off but for right now
there's still the novelty of it
so i walk into a place and i see tons of
people walking around
i think this is you know this is awesome
uh but all of those packed restaurants
these packed places
nothing bad is happening at least in
terms of the virus
you know there are no mass outbreaks
everything is fine
and by the way we're still in the middle
of a pandemic no we're not
in in this country no we're not not by
any not by any
reasonable definition of the term
pandemic
and of course we're not got tens of
millions people vaccinated
many more millions people already immune
because of prior exposure
and that's good we should be happy about
that
of course we should be happy
but just think of the mentality this is
like
talk about movies i mean this is like a
comic book movie villain
who who uh you know because you know the
comic book movies the villains
they always want to destroy the world
and they hate everybody and it's never
explained exactly
why this was because they're the villain
and this is the role that they play
and that's that's wajahat ali and a lot
of people on the left who are clinging
on to the pandemic
desperately they don't want it to go
away they do not want it to go away
they live through the pandemic and
they're sad to see it go
and now they they see people
enjoying themselves in a totally
safe way and they're angry
as curmudgeonly as i am i can't even
imagine that
i can't imagine i cannot even get myself
into the
mental state where i could see a
family sitting at a restaurant
having a good time laughing enjoying
themselves and getting mad about it
or be horrified
i would like to think that this dude is
this is a put on and he's
pretending to to react this way for
political reasons
and that might be part of it but but i
actually think
that this is a sincere reaction
these people have conditioned themselves
and it might never change i mean they're
these are broken people and they might
be broken forever
where they're never going to be able to
function in society again
just simply the sight of lots of people
having a good time horrifies them down
to their
bones in their souls they're horrified
by it
um i cannot think of a more
anti-human disposition for a person to
have
i wanted to play this to scotty pippen a
former nba player was on with
dan patrick yesterday discussing
a bulls playoff game in 1994
where the final shot was given to a
white player to shoot
rather than to him to scottie pippen and
he's still mad about it
this is you know we're going on 30 years
ago and he's still angry about it he's
decided
that the lakers coach at the time the
legendary phil jackson
is a racist because of it and he's still
stewing over this racism
let's uh let's watch this interview i'm
just going by what you said you said
you need to read between the fine lines
and then you go on to say
it was a racial move to give him tony
cucoch a rise
so i mean if you knew that scottie
pippen had been with the bulls from 87
battled through the pistons
and every other team that we had to get
to those three championships
wouldn't you give scottie pippen one
opportunity to get a last second shot
without michael jordan like one year
without michael jordan
can i get one shot like i'm doing all
the dirty work
but all of that i understand from the
basketball standpoint but when you say a
racial move
well why would why would tony who was a
rookie get the last second
shot and you put me up for violence
that's what i mean racial
like that was scottie pippen's team but
on pace to be a mvp that year right
yeah okay well why would you put him in
a position
not to be successful why wouldn't you
put him in a position
to succeed michael jordan is not there
so who's next in line for you
if you talk to phil about this because
you by saying a racial move
then you're you're calling phil a racist
i don't got a problem with that do you
think phil was
or is oh yeah
why didn't i get the last shot why did
you give it to him
dude this was 30 years ago get over it
that's the first thing
stop stop referring yourself in the
third person that's the other thing
three decades later and this guy is not
over the fact he didn't get the last
shot in a basketball game
yeah some of these professional sports
legends after
they it's it's really depressing to see
them after
michael jordan's the same way these guys
are on the same team
he said who could forget michael jordan
at his hall of fame
his hall of fame acceptance speech and
he's still complaining about his high
school basketball coach
and the ways that he was wronged by
people when he was a kid
still stewing over it you're in the hall
of fame now move on with your life you
won
uh it's it's really really sad and
pathetic to see sometimes but
he uh he says it was all racism he's
decided that it was all racism
as far as i know he's never made this
claim before you know in the 30 years
prior it's like the first
now he's decided it was all racism and
you see two things from that first of
all
you know there was a time not all that
long ago
where to call someone like phil jackson
a racist
legendary coach very prominent figure in
the in the
the sports world to call him a racist
especially for another prominent person
sports legend sort of to call him a
racist
that's a big deal you just you don't
do that on a whim there was a time
when that was the case um
there was a time when a prominent person
calling another prominent person
racist was attention grabbing and
everybody would stop and say whoa
hang on here and
if if you were if you were to make that
claim about someone
and this is back when the claim had some
kind of meaning to it
um if you were to make that claim you
better bring some proof
but now we're so used to it that guys
like scottie pippen first of all think
nothing of just tossing that out there
he's not even fully committing to the
racism label he's just saying yeah yeah
i don't have a problem with that
well yeah you're the one who said it i
guess you don't have a problem with it
yeah sure sure he's a racist
he's kind of shrugging his shoulders
yeah we'll call him a racist
what's the big deal in a way it's kind
of not a big deal anymore because
everyone's a racist as we said before
everything is everything so every so
everything is nothing everyone's a
racist
so nobody's a racist the word just
doesn't mean anything
but what you also see is how
um this is all the racism has become
if you're a non-white person
and someone does something to you
that you don't like it's racist
because this is this is simply the
framework that we're operating with now
that is the first explanation that you
go to and it's the only one
and the only evidence that you need is
well look at his skin color
look at mine i didn't like it it's
racist
all right before we move on to reading
the comments i do have a
after all this time off there's been a
lot of crazy stuff posted at tiktok i've
missed a lot of it
uh unfortunately i can't go back and
cover it all but let's check in
on one of my favorite tick tock genres
this is the
the tick tock sing along the tick tock
song
very often these are songs about getting
vaccinated and big fan of them here's
the hottest new joint on tick tock let's
give it a listen
[Music]
dropping facts the cdc says hey you can
relax but when i
go i'll still rock a mask cause i don't
want to be mistaken for a trap supporter
i'm fat
he says
i would do it all over again just
to chill with my friends
[Music]
i gotta say i don't totally hate it i
i i can't believe i i'm having all these
confusing feelings because
you expect to hate it and it's kind of
catchy as far as
i don't like the message okay but uh as
far as these things go the bar's pretty
low
as far as these tick tock videos go it
at least
succeeds in being catching can we admit
that
can we all don't leave me out here
hanging okay don't pretend like i said
let's all
have the courage to be normal insane
people we're going to admit that it's
kind of a catchy
hook at least that'll be stuck in your
head you know it will
you're going to find yourself singing
that later on today
don't shoot the messenger you're all
gonna pretend you hated that
you're pretending it wasn't terrible
that's all that's all i'm saying okay uh
this guy's going places
he's got some talent you know before we
went on our uh
on our long car trip uh i had a few
things that needed to be fixed on the
car
and that's why i went you know where i
went i went to rockauto.com that's where
i always go
because that's so much easier and it's
going to be a more immediate solution
an easier solution and cheaper solution
to your problem that you have with your
car than going to an auto parts store
and wandering around looking for the
part you're not going to find it
why waste your time rockauto.com always
offers the lowest prices possible
rather than changing prices or you know
just trying to see how much they can get
out of you they're not going to do that
if you see it at rockauto.com you have
peace of mind knowing
that that's the the lowest price you're
going to find it anywhere
uh they're a family business they've
been serving auto parts customers online
for 20 years
you can go to rockauto.com right now to
shop for auto and body parts from
hundreds of manufacturers
the catalog is uh very unique it's very
easy to navigate even for an idiot like
myself
you quickly see all the parts available
for your car truck you can also choose
the brand specifications and prices you
prefer
make it very easy to make it very
affordable what's to lose nothing so go
to rockauto.com right now see all the
parts available for your car truck and
remember as always to write walsh
in there how did you hear about us box
so they know that we sent you
let's move on now to uh reading the
youtube comments annie shoot
says uh quoting me she says
uh in a healthy country she would be
kicked off the team i was referring to
the
olympic athlete who turned her back on
the flag whatever her name was gwen
something like gwen berry wasn't it
i said she should be kicked out the team
andy schutz says for what i don't
understand
i thought we are against canceling
people well annie
you're talking to a guy who literally
has a segment on a show called the daily
cancellation i cancel people
daily that's why we call it the daily
cancellation i never said i'm against
canceling people i don't know where you
got that from
that's that's a thing that some silly
conservatives say oh we shouldn't be
canceling anyone
no i'm not against cancer i am not
against canceling people
in principle um i am against canceling
people
for the wrong reasons that's what i'm
against
okay and if by canceling we mean
what would be canceling in this case
kick her off the team
we shame her uh she should be shamed and
reviled
and kicked off the team if you want to
call that canceling
fine but that is a
inappropriate reaction to her behavior
her behavior was embarrassing and
disgraceful and she has demonstrated
that she
despises the country that she's supposed
to represent in the olympics
and and we should not have athletes who
openly despise our country
representing us on the global stage in
the olympics
so that is a reasonable justified
response
i'm not against shaming people
uh making calling for consequences for
their actions
the way some conservatives talk about it
now it's like they're pretending
that they believe that nobody should
ever be shamed for anything and no one
should ever face any consequence
stop it obviously sometimes the
it's just is th is this
a warranted reaction or not
what we refer to when we refer to cancel
culture
we're talking about an unwarranted
reaction where someone is
is facing unwarranted overblown
out of proportion backlash or
consequences
for doing or saying something either
that wasn't wrong
or even if it was wrong it doesn't uh it
it should not warrant this kind of
reaction
but yeah doing that on the uh as an
olympic athlete up on the stage on
national tv absolutely
and we'd be doing her a favor she hates
this country she shouldn't even want to
represent us
in the olympics we're uh what are we
oppressive bigoted systemically raised
this country
why would you want to represent a
country like that in the olympics
um elaine says matt can you please call
us sweet babies more often
we miss it uh well
look the sweet baby gang is back
together again
i'll never leave you again i promise
except for later on this week
i'll be leaving again but i'll be back
and then i'll leave periodically but
i'll i'll always return to the sweet
baby gang it's that much you you can
count on um daniel says
matt all i want to know is did you catch
any fish on vacation i did
catch uh a lot of fish i had a great day
on the water probably
great week on the water i should say uh
probably my largest
largemouth that i caught was uh you know
is at least six pounds i'm gonna call it
seven
i think it was a fair to call it a seven
pounder and uh it was
it was the the ego stroke that i needed
because i gotta say
here in tennessee i've been struggling
mightily with fishing it's supposed to
tennessee is supposed to be a fishing
mecca bass fishing mecca
one of the one of the bass fishing
capitals along with probably texas and
um but i have been doing terrible here
and i began to suspect that the problem
was me but then i go when i was on
vacation and
we were out of you know we were up north
and
uh it let me know that the problem is
not me okay aaron says
dear matt your uranus joke almost killed
me seriously i was
mowing my grass and laughed so hard
choking on my beer and almost hit a tree
lol thank you for being the greatest
commentator in the universe well i
specifically said i was not making a
uranus joke
i i i would never do i want to be very
clear i did not make
that joke i was saying that i wasn't
making the joke
i was making the joke in the context of
saying how i'm not going to make it
okay i'm far too mature for that
um alan says the thing that infuriates
me about this routine of finding gay
characters where there are none is that
it contradicts the notion of the
feminist left
that friendships between men should
display more kindness and explicit
affection but when two male characters
do that they obsess with their
friendship
declaring that of course they're lovers
what else could they be a great example
is frodo and sam the radical left just
love these kinds of contradicting one
two punches to beat you into submission
and indoctrination
uh yeah th that is a clear hypocrisy a
clear double standard
doesn't make any sense it's a
contradiction but you're also correct
that this is about beating us into
submission the double standard as we
said
is the point um mike says bullets have
gotten expensive so i'm keeping my death
threats to a minimum well that's
that's one reason that's one motivation
our current situation with ammo does
kind of remind me a little bit of what
was the old chris rock
joke where he says that uh he would let
everyone keep their guns but make
bullets cost like 500 a piece so that if
someone gets shot you really know they
had it coming
chris rock does the joke better than i
do but uh finally
another comment says i'm commenting with
feedback for the producers
the fake photo of matt's family on the
alternate camera angle is blocking our
view of matt's beautiful biceps
and the twisted steel of his muscles
please remove the photo thank you
well these are my friends and i would
never take the photo down
unless it blocks the view of my muscles
in which case get out of here
i just broke it it's a little more
aggressive than it needed to be but
i just i can't help myself i don't know
my own strength
now you have now you can see now you get
that angle
that you've been the bicep we could call
that the bicep camera really is what we
should call it
if you enjoy your history censorship
free which is hard to find these days
uh then you need to make sure you're a
daily wire member right now why
well because the daily wire is now
streaming created equal which is the
story of supreme court justice clarence
thomas and his journey
from humble beginnings in the segregated
south to the highest court in the land
which by the way he was the
second black american to ever make this
journey
you don't hear about that as much in the
media the documentary is only available
to daily wire members so if you want
more stories that diverge from the
accepted narrative the political
narrative go to dailywire.com
subscribe to get 20 off your new
membership with code justice
also i got to let you know that daily
wire has several open positions for our
in-house team in nashville
um and uh i i told you about a position
we had a few weeks ago and actually
there was someone listening to the show
and now they're part of the team okay
i'm changing lives over here on the matt
wall show that might be the one and only
life i've ever changed but hey
let's try again this week we're
highlighting a few openings in our
post-production department including a
video editor position as well as an
assistant video editor position
the video editor will use his or her
technical and creative abilities to cut
and assemble
raw video footage from various daily
wire products projects like the matte
wall show
means you get to stare at my face while
you're editing video
i think i just scared away every
potential applicant i'm sorry for that
to creatively support and emphasize
subject matter and videos through
compelling
uh editing and storytelling a minimum of
two years previous professional video
editing experience
is required for this opportunity the
assistant video editor will assist our
team of video editors by pulling and
assembling
media cuts performing quality control
and cuts and more
previous video editing experience as
well as strong organizational skills
are required for this opportunity these
are full-time in-office positions
in nashville tennessee if you want to
move to nashville
now's your chance it's 98 degrees with
humidity of 150
right now who won't want some of that
candidates but we're inside we have air
conditioning so don't worry about it
candidates should apply through
dailywire.com careers
a link to your real and or portfolios
required for consideration for both of
these positions
now let's get to our daily cancellation
[Music]
in a stunning display of courage a white
british tick-tock influencer
has revealed to the world that he
identifies as korean ali london is his
name he's been getting plastic surgery
for several years
in an effort to as a newsweek article
puts it resemble their k-pop idol
jimin of bts i have only a vague idea
what any of those words mean but the
upshot
is that now london who also identifies
as non-binary has completed his surgical
transition and is ready to fully live
his life as the gender fluid korean that
he's always been deep down
for too long he has had a korean trapped
inside his body and now
with 150 000 of assistance from cosmetic
surgeons
his true east asian self has emerged
like a bruised and swollen butterfly
from a fleshy cocoon in a video recorded
just after his latest procedure ali
explains
that his surgically adjusted eyes and
nose and other features
now confirm confirm him
as a tried and true korean and i think
the case that he makes is pretty
bulletproof
let's listen
hey guys i'm finally korean i've
transitioned
i'm so so happy i've completed my look
i'm finally korean guys i have the eyes
just had a brow lift as well um so i'm
so happy
finally i've been trapped in the wrong
body for eight years
and that's the worst feeling in the
world when you're trapped and you don't
feel
like you can be yourself but finally i'm
korean i can be myself
and i'm so so happy
he looks happy finally he is korean it's
as simple as that
bigots might voice disagreement
insisting that one must actually be
from korea or at least have korean
citizenship in order to be considered in
any sense korean
they might even argue that surgically
narrowing your eyes to resemble asian
facial features not only fails to make
you asian but is also highly insulting
and degrading to the real asians of
which you are not one but ali definitely
countered these arguments in a series of
tweets
disarming and debunking such
discriminatory talking points he wrote
quote
being transsexual is the same as being
transracial because you're born in the
wrong body
in other tweets he announced that quote
trans rights are human rights
and that quote there are millions of
underrepresented transracial people in
the world
and i want to elevate their voices and
help them live their truth and be
themselves
now these may be more assertions than
arguments more spitting slogans than
making a case
but if if that's been sufficient for
transgender advocates then why shouldn't
it work for a trans-racial pioneer
driving the point home ali i think
really vanquished his critics once and
for all
by dropping the ultimate progressive
trump card in a different video listen
this is my reason for sharing the flag
and i do identify as korean this is my
choice this is my decision
it's not hurting anyone
there you go his decision his choice
not hurting anyone that's really it
right
in the age of psychological man when all
that matters is an individual's mental
states and all that you must do to
justify an action
is claim that the action makes you feel
good and causes no direct physical harm
to anyone else
whether or not the latter is actually
true the validity of a white man's
transformation in that context into a
genderless korean cannot be denied
certainly if you accept trans ideology
then you have absolutely
no logical basis for denying ali's truth
a truth which is grounded in the exact
same premise
a truth which must indeed be true if the
premise is true
and the premise to remind you is that a
person's physical
biological identity is totally
determined
by how they feel about themselves
a man who feels like a woman is not
merely a feminine man but is
actually a literal woman all of the
physical
barriers which have for millennia serve
to separate men from women are dissolved
and discarded biology is subordinated
to the emotional whims of the individual
why should ali's emotional whims not be
afforded the same supernatural weight
his case based on the logic of
progressivism is airtight
based on the logic of well logic it's
not at all but based on the logic of
progressivism it is
and yet the left has not accepted him
comments on the internet about his
racial transition have been
overwhelmingly negative
the daily wire documents a few of them
reading now it says i'm sorry but you
can't just choose to be korean
it's a nationality and ethnicity tweeted
one trans-identifying account
you have to be born korean just because
you like the culture doesn't mean you
can take it and
become it there is a way to appreciate a
different culture this
is not it quote as a korean non-binary
person i haven't really talked about the
ali london thing but the fact that
they're acting like it's genuine that
it's part of a journey
due to an identity issue really irks me
it's a mockery of trans people
it's cultural appropriation posted
another person finally one korean user
replied that while he celebrated
london's new gender identity it's wrong
for him to claim a new ethnic identity
korean isn't a pronoun nor is it a
persona you decide to suddenly take on
because of k-pop hype
i'm glad you identify as non-binary and
i applaud you for being transparent
about that
but i can't commend you for taking a
whole ethnicity and treating it like a
persona
hmm taking a whole ethnicity and
treating it like a persona
almost like when someone takes a
biological sex and treats those
i don't know an article in the left-wing
paper mag
written by sandra song editor-at-large
and a fellow korean
is just one long transphobic harangue
against the entire trans-racial
community
song writes quote as someone who
actually has korean dna though
i can say that some white fetishists as
proven by those 15 surgeries to look
look like jimin suddenly deeming
themselves
korean is incredibly offensive
especially since it effectively
trivializes our identities
because they're suddenly trendy
apparently though that doesn't really
register for ali who's continually been
a notable example of western
fetishization
that's objectified us based on south
korea's recent contributions to global
culture
so yeah obviously it's pretty sus that a
white person is tr is saying they're
korean
now leaving aside the embarrassing fact
that the magazine's editor at large
wrote and published the words
so yeah and pretty sus the real problem
is that she would accuse a person of
fetishizing
and trivializing her identity simply
because he is cartoonishly mimicking her
appearance and claiming that his
degraded mockery
is as authentic as her own identity i
mean she's essentially arguing
that his imitation is an imitation
and thus cannot be as valid or real as
the thing he is imitating
and her points make a lot of sense come
to think of it
but unfortunately she like nearly
everyone else in her ideological camp
has already thrown open the doors and
invited men to fetishize
and trivialize and mimic her identity
it's just that she wishes the mimicry
would stay contained to her sex not her
ethnicity
the problem though is that sex is far
more objective
and far less fluid than ethnicity
if the former can be erased then so can
the latter
ollie london knows that and now he's
entitled to
be seen as fully korean just as korean
as any other korean
indeed he may be even more korean than
cis koreans
like sandra song i mean you can make
that argument
this at least was a choice uh that he
has made
bravely if cis koreans don't want to
tolerate or accept trans koreans
that's their problem and their bigotry
they have to work through
it'd be better for them to just remain
silent in the meantime while the march
of progress continues
and all objective markers of identity
are erased
and human existence is reduced to a
murky puddle of ambiguity
that is the world the left wanted and
now they have it
congratulations and that is why the
bigots who would deny the validity of
ali london's korean identity
are today absolutely and with great
righteous rage cancelled
and we'll leave it there for today
thanks for watching thanks for listening
have a great day
godspeed
[Music]
the matt walsh show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producers are mathis
glover and robert sterling
our technical director is austin stevens
production manager pavel vadasky
the show is edited by sasha tolmachov
our audio is mixed by mike coromina
hair makeup is done by nika geneva and
our production coordinator is mckenna
waters
the matte wall show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 21.
the nfl comes out of the closet a
british dude transitions to become a
korean
and supreme court originalists defend
the supposed constitutional right
of dudes to use the women's bathroom
check it out on the michael knowles show